[Music]
2020 has been a pretty tricky year for
movies
luckily the calendar is already filling
up for the next few years
and a whole heap of exciting projects
are slated for release
here are some of the biggest films
arriving in 2021
and beyond after the runaway success of
2018's a quiet place
it seemed almost inevitable that a
sequel would soon follow
after all the film ended in a perfect
position to set up the next chapter of
the story
and there was no small amount of fan
demand for another
installment either by 2019 writer
director john krasinski was back on
board to make the sequel
and a quiet place part 2 was on track to
arrive in theaters in the spring of
2020. the second chapter of the saga
will follow the surviving members of the
abbott
family as they attempt to venture out
beyond their farm
meanwhile it looks like the story will
flash back to reveal what happened the
day the world
started to fall apart showing how
krazynski's character lee first led his
family in the early days of the crisis
a quiet place part two was originally
set to hit theaters on march of 2020 but
the kovid 19 pandemic forced a change in
scheduling
the sequel was initially pushed to
september of the same year
but when it became clear that this
wasn't all that feasible either it was
then moved to its current release date
april 23 2021 the ninth film in the fast
and furious series was supposed to have
been released in may 2020
but growing concerns over the spread of
the coronavirus in march
led universal pictures to move the
film's release date back
nearly a year now fans will have to wait
until april 2nd 2021
to see dominic toretto and his crew face
off against a dangerous new toretto
brother
this time played by john cena the news
came after f9 had
already had the promotional red carpet
rolled out in the form of a heavily
teased first
trailer which also revealed the
long-awaited return of han to the
furious fold
the real question now is what this means
for the planned
tenth installment in the furious
franchise fast10 originally held the
april 2021 date
now held by its predecessor obviously
the coronavirus has put a squeeze on
film production around the world
so fans probably shouldn't expect two
films in this franchise to drop in the
same year
that said never count dom and his family
out
fast 10 might arrive sooner than you
think
after the 2016 ghostbusters reboot
failed to launch a new film series in
its own right
it seemed like the beloved supernatural
comedy franchise might never hit the big
screen again
but that all changed in 2019 when
director jason reitman revealed that
he'd been quietly working on a new film
set
within the continuity of the first two
movies
ghostbusters co-creator dan aykroyd had
worked on a version of a third film for
years but now with reitman on board with
his own
new take the original series is finally
set to continue
i love this plan i'm excited to be a
part of it let's do
it this job is definitely not worth 11 5
a year
ghostbusters afterlife will be set in
the present day
and follow a family who moved to rural
oklahoma after inheriting some land from
the kid's mysterious grandfather who
possibly turns out to be original
ghostbuster egon spangler
ghostbusters afterlife was originally
set to hit theaters in the summer of
2020
but due to the coronavirus pandemic the
film is now set to arrive march
5th 2021 venom was one of the biggest
comic book movie hits of 2018
and by far the most surprising the film
did so well in fact that sony quickly
green lit a sequel
and soon after motion capture legend
andy circus stepped up to direct it
as promised by the first movie's
post-credits scene
the second venom will indeed focus on
the madman known as
cletus cassidy whose comic book
counterpart is famous for becoming the
super villain known as
carnage tom hardy will return as eddie
brock and woody harrelson will play
cassidy himself
in april 2020 the film was also given a
pretty appropriate title
venom let there be carnage though it was
originally scheduled to arrive in the
fall of 2020
venom let there be carnage was delayed
by the coronavirus pandemic
and will now hit theaters on june 25th
2021
in the spring of 2022 just over five
years after his
mcu debut dr strange will finally get
his very
first sequel movie marvel studios
announced at san diego comic con that
director scott derrickson and star
benedict cumberbatch
would both return for doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness
which derrickson promised would be the
first truly scary film in the marvel
cinematic universe
in early 2020 however derrickson vacated
the director's chair due to
so-called creative differences with
marvel and horror legend
sam raimi was later confirmed as his
replacement
strange won't be the only hero in the
flick either he'll be joined by wanda
maximoff who'll once again be played by
elizabeth olsen
scarlet witch's appearance in the film
will also tie in directly to the events
of juan division
a disney plus series starring olson
alongside paul bettany as the vision
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness hits theaters on march 25th
2022 it's been more than 30 years since
top gun roared into theaters
and the film is still considered one of
the best blockbusters of tom cruise's
career
the story of a navy fighter pilot who
refuses to play by the rules the film
remains a classic piece of 1980s action
i feel the need the need
for speed and now after years of teasing
from crews himself
fans are finally getting a sequel top
gun
maverick sees cruz returning to the
title role of maverick
now a much older man who's still pushing
the envelope as a pilot and refusing
promotions that would take him out of
the cockpit for good though he's happy
to continue in his old ways
maverick's life is upended by a new
dangerous top gun mission
and the arrival of bradley bradshaw the
son of his late friend goose
promising plenty of aerial action top
gun maverick also sees the return of top
gun star val kilmer
as well as a number of franchise
newcomers including jon hamm
jennifer connolly ed harris and more
maverick was originally supposed to
arrive june 2020
before being delayed to december the
film is now set to land
july 2nd 2021 for some time now
legendary pictures monsterverse has been
working to unite the biggest kaiju in
cinema history
what began with godzilla in 2014 and
continued through
kong skull island and godzilla king of
the monsters
was always leading to a moment when the
two most famous
giant movie monsters of all time would
clash on screen
now it's almost here in the form of
godzilla vs
kong the showdown between the
radioactive lizard and skyscraper
scaling gorilla
adam wingard is in the director's chair
this time working with an ensemble cast
that includes a host of returning
monster vs stars
as well as newcomers alexander skarsgard
rebecca hall
and aza gonzalez the film promises to
feature the titular battle of course
but it'll also provide more insights
into the origins of the titans
themselves
deepening the mythology around the
headline monsters godzilla vs kong was
originally set to arrive in november
2020
but the kovid 19 pandemic led to a
reshuffle
the film is now set to hit theaters may
21st
2021 in august 2019
spider-man's future was thrown into
serious jeopardy when reports
surfaced that sony pictures and disney
were unable to reach a new agreement
concerning their shared rights to the
character
since 2015 spider-man has had one foot
in sony's solo films
and one foot in the marvel cinematic
universe thanks to an agreement that
allowed the studios to share him
when attempts to renegotiate that
agreement fell apart spidey's mcu future
seem to fall apart with them
but in late september that year the
dispute between the studios was finally
settled
after a tense few weeks for fans sony
and disney agreed to a renewed
partnership with spider-man
that will take the character through at
least one more solo film
and one more appearance in an unnamed
future mcu film
setting the stage for the next phase of
the character's marvel adventures
very little is currently known about
what those adventures will look like
but we do at least know that after a few
delays the still
untitled third spider-man film will
swing into
theaters on december 17 2021
while spider-man has spent the last few
years hanging out with the avengers over
the marvel cinematic universe
the film rights to all of the webb
slinger's supporting characters remain
at sony pictures
and they've been hard at work on their
own shared universe of
spidey adjacent heroes and villains
after venom became a box office hit in
2018
that effort was stepped up and in the
spring of 2021
morbius will become the second spidey
villain to get his own solo movie
jared leto stars as michael morbius the
first live-action version of the living
vampire from the pages of marvel comics
as he searches for a cure for a rare
blood disease that could kill him
morbius accidentally alters his own
biological makeup
and gives himself a kind of vampirism
which also grants him superhuman
abilities
the first trailer for the film leaned
heavily into the darker aspects of the
morbius story but also teased that
michael keaton will make some kind of
appearance as adrian toombs
his character from spider-man homecoming
though it was originally scheduled for
the summer of 2020
morbius was delayed by the coronavirus
pandemic and will now hit theaters on
march 19
2021 when mission impossible 3 arrived
with the lowest box office numbers of
the series in 2006
it seemed that the action franchise was
falling apart never count tom cruise out
though
the impossible films found their footing
again with ghost protocol in 2011
and they've been building steam ever
since with 2018's fallout ranking as the
most financially successful and
critically acclaimed installment yet
naturally it made sense to continue the
series and after the success of fallout
it seemed like writer director
christopher maquari
was the man to do it at first macquarie
was reluctant to try and top his last
installment but he eventually agreed to
do not one
but two films in the series which are
being shot back to back
the first of these mission impossible 7
will arrive
november 19 2021 with the eighth film in
the franchise landing on november 4th
2022 tom cruise will return as ethan
hunt
and rebecca ferguson is also expected to
be back as his mysterious ally
ilsa faust among the many other
characters expected to make their return
to the franchise is henry cherny
who hasn't been seen since the original
movie in 1996
everything else is being kept firmly
under wraps but you can pretty much
guarantee that whatever cruz and
macquarie have in store
is going to be pretty darn spectacular
while the events of avengers endgame
seem to herald the end of both iron man
and captain america in the mcu
one other franchise from the old days
still has a few things left to say
yes thor is returning to his solo series
once again for a fourth installment
thor love and thunder marvel studios
made the announcement at san diego comic
con 2019
having already confirmed that thor
ragnarok director taiko watiti
would be back as both writer and
director for the next film
chris hemsworth will return in the title
role alongside tessa thompson as
valkyrie
as well as a rather more surprising cast
member natalie portman
who walked away from the role of jane
foster after thor the dark world
and what's more jane will get to pick up
mjolnir this time around
signaling an adaptation of the 2010s
comic book saga in which foster became
the new
thor the jam-packed thor love and
thunder
arrives february 11 2022
it's been 20 years since the matrix
changed cinema forever but it's a
blockbuster combination of
gravity-defying action and existential
sci-fi storytelling
the film went on to spawn two sequels
but after the matrix revolutions it
seemed like neo's journey had come to a
definitive end
that changed in summer of 2019 when
variety reported that matrix co-creator
lana wachowski
was returning to write and direct a
fourth installment of the beloved
franchise
and she wouldn't be alone either
wachowski's return came with the news
that original stars keanu reeves
and carrie anne moss would also be back
in their respective starring roles
as neo and trinity
a few months later warner brothers
announced that the film would arrive may
21
2021 it later ended up pushed back to
april 2022
very little is known about what exactly
will bring neo and trinity back to the
matrix after all these years
after all while there was a certain
ambiguity to the ending of the matrix
revolutions
it did at least seem to resolve the
journey of those characters
wachowski obviously had a new idea
though and watching one of the
franchise's original creators return
with a fresh
take is too good of an opportunity to
pass up
now that avengers endgame has brought
the epic infinity saga storyline to a
close
the marvel cinematic universe as we know
it is about to undergo some major
changes
yes familiar characters won't remain but
they won't be alone for long
a whole heap of new heroes are coming
over the horizon
including the mcu's first all-new
superhero team since the guardians of
the galaxy debuted in 2014.
based on the marvel comics team of the
same name eternals
will follow a near immortal race of
beings who have secretly lived on earth
for thousands of years
following some kind of unexpected
tragedy in the wake of endgame
they will be forced out of hiding and
back into an ages-long battle against
the deviants
their ancient enemy the film boasts a
star-packed cast
including angelina jolie salma hayek
richard madden kumail nanjiani
brian tyree henry gemma chan and more
not only are mcu fans getting a new team
but they're also getting the most
diverse
cast of superhero characters in the mcu
to date
including their first openly gay
superhero and first
death character though it was originally
scheduled to arrive in the fall of 2020
the coronavirus pandemic has shifted
marvel's entire release schedule
and eternals will now land on february
12th
2021 there have been plenty of
spider-man movies in the 21st century so
far but none of them ever struck a chord
quite like spider-man
into the spider-verse the film marked
the first time spidey had hit the big
screen as the star of an animated film
and the creative team took full
advantage of that by crafting a truly
remarkable visual style
spider-verse also opted for a more
diverse approach to its characters
by making ultimate spider-man miles
morales the lead character
and surrounding him with alternate
universe spider heroes of all kinds
it can get weirder i just wash my hands
that's why they're wet
no other reason the result was an almost
universally beloved instant classic
a film that took home box office gold
and then began
filling up a trophy case with awards
including the oscar for best animated
feature
sony pictures was so high on the
spider-verse concept that the sequel
was in the works even before the film
hit theaters and it turned out that
excitement was justified
now it's just a matter of time the
sequel to into the spider-verse will
chronicle the further adventures of
miles morales
and is set to hit theaters october 7th
2022.
though he may be the fastest of dc's
on-screen superheroes the flash has been
taking his sweet time getting to the big
screen in his own solo movie
development on a dc eu film starring the
scarlet speedster has stretched back
nearly a decade
with various writers and directors
lining up for the project
only to eventually depart ezra miller
then debuted as barry allen with a brief
cameo in batman vs superman
dawn of justice before going on to star
in justice league in 2017
since then a number of changes have
forced miller's flash solo film to hop
around the calendar
now it seems it may have finally found
its spot
with it director andy muschietti and
birds of prey writer christina hodson
taking the reins the flash is now
expected to arrive in 2022
provided it can make it to the finish
the film is a sure fire to be a hit
let's just hope it can actually make it
off the starting line
like the flash jason mamoa's aquaman
first appeared in a brief cameo in
batman vs superman dawn of justice
before going on to become one of justice
league's biggest scene stealers for his
first solo film director james wan
and momoa delivered a massive underseat
epic that combined superhero adventure
with epic fantasy storytelling and a
brighter more comedic outlook than
previous dceu films
the result was a box office mega hit
that grossed more than one billion
dollars after its release
during the 2018 holiday season with that
in mind
a sequel was pretty much inevitable in
february 2019
warner brothers announced that aquaman 2
was indeed moving forward
and would arrive in theaters four years
after the first film mamoa is set to
return to reprise his
role as the titular superhero and juan
has signed on to produce and possibly
direct
two aquaman twos flashes down in
theaters on december 16
2022 check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one